let's move on to this critical race
theory nonsense so you know one of the
things that's happening over the last
couple weeks
is that finally because i think people
like me and
people in these circles and people
online it's very similar actually to the
story that i just talked about with joe
biden
because the online people have been
exposing critical race theory
for its neo-racism for the systemic
racism which it wants to put into the
system
for the idea that white people in
essence are born guilty and are guilty
over
the uh the sins of their
forefathers or actually not even for
their forefathers because no one in my
family owned
slaves so why would i be guilty of what
someone in my family did generations ago
i shouldn't be and it didn't even happen
so they want you to be guilty by the
color of your skin
they've decided the critical race
theorists and the intersectionalists
the intersectionalityists and the
websters they've decided
that things like being on time and
working hard and empirical facts like
two plus two equals
four that these are uh tools of
oppression and white supremacy and
everything else
well one of the things that's happened
in the last month is as this has been
more and more exposed by people online
and chris ruffo specifically who i'm
going to get to
in just a moment then suddenly the meme
went out
that no critical race theory doesn't
really exist
or it's not really what you're all
saying it is or it's just not really
being put into the institutions and it's
just sort of another
right-wing conspiracy theory sort of
like joe biden's cognitive problems
well actually we are seeing it infect
absolutely everything so chris ruffo who
you guys know who is a lawyer
he has done incredible work bringing
lawsuits into a bunch of different red
states of course it's red states
to fight critical race theory in schools
in that you wouldn't want children to be
taught neo-racism the same way you
wouldn't want
children to be taught nazism that it's
good you know what i mean you could
teach about nazis that's a very
different thing
but chris is doing a great job with this
he sent out this incredible tweet
uh and i'm gonna he bulleted it out i'm
just gonna read you some of it so
breaking
the nation's largest teachers union has
approved a plan to promote
critical race theory in all 50 states
and in 14 000 local school districts
the argument that critical race theory
isn't in
k k through 12 schools is officially
dead
the union has also approved funding for
increasing the implementation of crt
in k-12 curricula and for attacking
conservative groups who oppose
crt indoctrination the teachers union
has made critical race theory its number
one priority
and want to implement it nationwide
according to a recent yougov
survey 58 of americans oppose
critical race theory including 72
percent of independents who believe
teaching it in schools is bad for
america
but the teachers union wants to double
down and impose this divisive ideology
on your children
the nea represents 3 million public
school
employees in all 50 states they have a
350
million dollar annual budget and an army
of operatives
in 14 000 local communities so we've got
a little more
info on this but before i get to that
the key piece of this
is that what we've been hearing for the
last couple weeks is no it's not
really in schools no it doesn't really
exist well now we know it does
the gateway pundits got a little bit
more laws banning
the instruction of critical race theory
tenets in public schools have passed in
more than 20 states
and there is reason to hope that the
tide is beginning to turn in the fight
for the country's history and principles
unfortunately the zen education project
refuses to accept defeat
and desires to teach american children
that this country was founded upon the
dispossession
of native americans slavery structural
racism and oppression
as opposed to the principles of liberty
enshrined in the declaration of
independence and the constitution
now the zep is circulating a pledge to
teach the truth
which identifies left-wing methods of
analysis like critical race theory as
the truth
and decrees that the signees all of whom
are educators
refuse to be bullied into compliance
with the law so far according to the zen
education project
the pledge has been signed by more than
5 000 educators
in all 50 states and many of the signees
were more than happy to provide their
reasons
for signing so what is happening here in
effect
is that roughly these 20 red states that
are now passing these laws
to keep systemic racism
new school pernicious racism of the left
out of schools there are now groups
that are actually getting teachers to
basically say we will ignore the law
and we will teach the quote-unquote
truth
regardless this battle ain't going
anywhere and i saw an interesting back
and forth
uh between chris ruffo and james lindsey
who i've also had on the show many times
who's i think one of the
the prime um the prime purveyors of the
truth when it comes to critical race
theory
uh in essence james lindsey was saying
that he's not hopeful that uh despite
the fact that he has now spent the last
few years of his life fighting against
critical race theory
in many ways more than almost anyone
that he's not very hopeful that this
thing is just coming and coming and
coming and it's going to get worse and
we're going to end up in some sort of
south africa situation roofo tweeted
back and said that he's optimistic
and and i responded and i basically said
that
i'm a world weary optimist that's the
way i always describe myself i would say
i'm an optimist because how could i talk
about the news how could i talk about
the things i believe in
every day if i wasn't an optimist if i
didn't believe
that by me communicating these ideas to
you guys
that hopefully that gives you some of
the tools to take the right ideas to
your family and community and everything
else and then and then build a better
world that would make me an optimist
but i'm not just a blind eyed optimist
right i'm not just someone that thinks
just because we
say nice things or believe the right
thing or fight for the truth that
magically
these things um grow like i just don't
believe that so i would say i'm world
weary in that regard i'm a realist
and my argument to them in effect was
well look
as a world weary optimist i don't think
we can stop it but i think we can
actually basically inoculate the new
the new converts right like the new
people who are about to be brainwashed
we can do something to save them
but this thing's here these diversity
and inclusion
programs that are in so many of the
fortune 500 companies that are
most likely in the companies you work
for or the schools that you're sending
your kids to or whatever it might be
they're here those things are now
infected and cannot be saved i really
believe that
because even if they were to be saved
the damage that would happen in in terms
of saving them
like how can you have an organization
that believes that it's racist and was
going to hire based on skin color and
gender and all of these things
how can it reverse that oh sorry we got
that wrong we're actually going to start
hiring
based on skill and passion and you know
education and the rest of it
you can't reverse it so the only thing
that we can do
is build new things